if you want to be a true reborn
Christian you need to follow Jesus
Christ because he is the truth the word
of God John 1 verse1 in the beginning
was the word and the Word was with God
and the Word was God if you follow him
if you truly love Jesus Christ with
everything that is in you you will obey
his word John 14:15 says if you love me
you will keep my
Commandments please listen to me today
you cannot just follow certain parts of
scripture certain parts of the Bible
that fits in with your lifestyle and
leave the rest you either commit to God
fully and change your lifestyle
according to scripture or you're
deceiving yourself and you're a lukewarm
Christian which means you're a fake
Christian